On this episode India
turns into the Professor.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 222 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Beautiful day in New York City.
Dunk is Periscoping oh
he's double fisted.
I like that.
Doing something else.
And India has transformed
into an elderly, not elderly,
by India standards, an
older gentleman from Europe.
- Mhmmm.
- True.
Why don't you tell the Vayner
Nation who you are, what you're
doing here for the week and then
a little bit about yourself?
- I'm Niklas Myhr, the
social media professor--
- Not me, them.
- And I actually find your take
on education quite refreshing.
You're not the biggest fan
obviously but I thought I would
get a cold shower of reality
this week so thank you for the
internship opportunity.
The reverse internship.
Learning the real world at
VaynerMedia to see what kind of
world my students get
into when they get out.
- That's great.
We've known each other for
a nice little while now.
Where do you teach?
- I teach at Chapman University
in southern California which is
a good private college and
we put out MBA students and
undergrads hopefully to
VaynerMedia and
other places in the world.
- Awesome. It's great
to have you.
How's it going so far?
How's Andy?
Andy's, show Andy,
he's a tough guy.
- [Niklas] Yeah.
- [Gary] I wouldn't
want to work for him.
I'm glad that he works for me.
- [Niklas] Put me to
work sorting staplers.
- So what are we,
is today Tuesday?
So yesterday was the first day.
- Yeah.
- What's your first 36 hour
observation of Vayner?
Obviously it's a
new fancy office.
- Yeah.
- Your timing was great.
- Did you plan that on purpose?
- Perfect.
Very impressed, people are
really looking like they fit in
and they're really focused
and everyone is talking about
Musical.ly so I started started
a Musical.ly account yesterday
and my 12-year-old
daughter saw it.
Always got to learn.
- I love it. I love it.
- It seems to be people are
really taking this job seriously
but they seem to work for
the passion and seem
to be motivated intrinsically.
- Great.
- Very impressive.
- Well, appreciate it.
Alright, let's
get into the show.
Good to see everybody.
I'm really looking
forward to the fall.
I'm trying not to travel as much
in September so hopefully we'll
get into a great
cadence after Labor Day.
One things you guys should
know just for general content
purposes start in the middle of
of next week taking a good two
and half weeks with the
family so we'll be very quiet.
There'll be a lot
of DJing content.
Andy, we can finally find all
those little short video clips
that are deeply
entrenched somewhere.
I feel like Dunk should watch
every hour of raw footage of
every DailyVee so that's 60 by
then times about eight
hours each?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I mean, 480 hours worth
of raw footage of just me.
Alright, let's do it.
First question, who's asking it?
- Parsa has a video question here.
- Okay.
- Hey Gary, this is Parsa.
What do you think about using
Snapchat as a way to sell and
buy products with Snap Cash?
Would that be
Snapchat's next big move?
- Parsa, I think it is
an interesting thought.
Obviously a lot of people in
the US and Europe entrepreneurs
scene are affected by WeChat's
unbelievable success of not only
being a content and a
communication but a retail
platform in China.
I think Snap Cash is
something that Snapchat
is de-prioritizing.
I think on the flip side,
I think we're going to see
a lot more commerce
coming from Facebook.
I predict that a lot of you
will be selling a ton of stuff
through Facebook 24
months from today.
I think Parsa for
Snapchat I'm not sure.
I think that they're, internally
I'm sure they're thinking
about their roadmap.
I'm curious to think about what
they're thinking about Instagram
Stories, do they feel like one
of the observations that I'm
kind of leaning towards is
I don't think Instagram Stories
kills Snapchat but I definitely
think it may slow down the
migration of 35 to 55-year-olds
over to the platform if they can
use Instagram to feed
that kind of storytelling.
So how are they
thinking about that?
I was bullish and
excited about Snap Cash.
I thought it was a good
move by them way back when.
I think it's
something you can consider.
My intuition is what you're
trying to accomplish ends up
becoming a big business within
Facebook in the next 24 months.
- Awesome.
- Ted?
- I'm learning the ropes.
Ted has a video question.
- Let's do it.
- What's going on Gary?
Big fan.
My name is Ted Bettridge and
I'm a 13-year-old graphic
designer from the UK.
I've recently started my design
company and I'm presenting it on
Instagram, Twitter, Snapchat
and just about to start YouTube.
I'm proud of being a 13-year-old
designer and I think I can use
that as a growth hack to make
myself better known out there.
But some clients when they find
out that I'm 13 take that back
as a negative without
actually seeing my work
and knowing the full story.
So how would you recommend me
going around presenting myself
and my business as a
13-year-old designer?
Cheers Gary.
- Cheers mate.
Teddy, listen, I think you're
all excited up front of like I'm
gonna differentiate myself
by being 13 and then you're like
but some clients don't like it.
Of course.
You're 13.
Literally Andy has
speakers older than you. Right?
This is unbelievable.
And your composure and
your charisma on the video,
you're going to be very successful.
I have a funny feeling at
whatever you decide to do.
The same way I met Dunk
when we met in the hotel room.
I'm like, "You're
coming to America."
Some young kids just have it.
I could tell way more because
I spent more time with them to
know that he did have it.
I'm not sure about you that's a
good first impression for me.
Getting on the show at all.
But here's the reality, my
friend, Ted, you're going to
learn this at 13, you're going
to learn this at 16,
you're going to
learn this at 19,
learn this at 27,
you're going
to learn it at 40.
How old are you?
- [Niklas] 53.
- You look great.
You're going to learn it at 53.
As I'm sure you know what
I'm about to say is true,
you gotta take the
good with the bad.
You gotta take the
For everybody who's going to
give you notoriety or write an
article about you our actually
use you 'cause you're 13 there's
going to be people that don't.
For everybody that loves that
I keep it real and authentic
there's plenty of people
that don't want to work with me
because I curse or because
I push against the
traditional systems.
- Not at Social
Media Marketing World.
- Did they like it?
- Yeah.
- Yes, they did, you're right.
The punchline is very
simple which is this,
Teddy, you need to be you.
Don't hide that you're 13 'cause
you think you'll
earn more money.
You're 13 and if you got real
talent, that's going to serve
you extremely well.
I think the reality is
how would I play it?
By just being you and doing your
thing and not dwelling on the
negatives and not getting too
big headed about the positives.
Don't get too upset when
somebody cancels an order when
they found out you're 13 and
don't think you're hot shit just
'cause somebody wrote some cool
Business Insider headline that
says 13-year-old stuns with
his graphical design skills.
- [Niklas] Wonderful.
- Thank you.
- [Niklas] Chris has
a question for you.
- Okay.
- [Voiceover] Chris asked,
"If the Jets win the Super Bowl
"before you buy the team,
will you lose interest?"
- So I've been really
scared of this question.
This is actually a true story.
I did not want this question to
be asked because the truth is
I don't know.
Let's start there.
I love how I'm looking
into yonder trying to
find my future self.
(group laughter)
Basically, I'm looking
outside right now and
I'm like picturing myself
jumping over a fence and running
on the field and tackling
Brandon Marshall and
getting arrested.
I don't think I'll
want to buy them.
- [Niklas] Wow.
- Not only that
I got something scarier.
I don't know if I'm going
to care about them at all.
I'm telling you Ken Skelfo if
you're watching right now
please leave a comment.
Ken Skelfo, will tell you that
15-year-old me in 1982 and
North Hunterdon High School was
a bigger New York Ranger fan
than a New York Jets fan.
And that is the
hidden story of who I am.
I always wanted buy the Jets
so that's kind of interesting,
so football was my true favorite
sport but the Jets weren't good
and so you lose steam and the
Rangers were making their march
to my first championship that
was won right there,
one of the great
moments of my life.
And I think that, here's what I
can tell you if the Jets win the
Super Bowl this year, three
years now, six years now before
I get a chance to buy them and
when the Super Bowl there is a
significant chance that all
of my sports energy will be
deployed aggressively towards
the New York Knicks because they
would be my last
team that hasn't won.
They've already got a big part
of my attention they just been
so bad for 15 years, it siphoned
any excitement out of my body.
I'm very, I'm very
concerned about this question.
It's actually the scariest
question besides the things I
care about which are the health
of my family it's one of the
weird scariest
things in my life.
I do not want the Jets, deep
down I don't think I want the
Jets to win the Super Bowl.
- [Niklas] I'm a hockey fan from
Sweden you can go with
the with the Rangers.
- Our goalie, Mr. Lundquist.
Alright.
- Alright, then
we have Gus here.
- Gus.
- [Voiceover] Gus asks, "Which
pro athlete or celebrity is the
"most marketable but
isn't monetizing it yet?"
- Oh, that's a great question.
Who is the most monetizable
celebrity or athlete right now
who's under monetizing?
Okay so I don't know the answer
because I don't really dig too
deep into that world.
I mean I know but I don't know.
And I don't like talking about
things I don't know but I'm a
give a very smart answer.
I believe on looks and charisma
it is somebody who's an athlete
that is not a star player.
So what I mean by that is
I believe that, well look,
Chris Humphries, right?
He's a very solid, gutsy
rebounding NBA player but he
became dramatically more famous
and could monetize because
Kim Kardashian and him
dated and they actually
got married for four minutes.
I think that that's a good comp.
I think there's a stunningly
handsome or beautiful man or
woman who's an athlete who's
not the star of their team who
either is gorgeous and can play
the modeling role along with
athlete though that doesn't play
out 'cause sports a lot of times
they'll rag on you that you're
just pretty and you can't
get it done on the field.
I actually think as
I'm talking this through
it's the most charismatic.
So what do I mean by that?
I believe that that somebody
started vlogging Casey Neistat,
Casey style right now in the NBA
as the ninth man off the bench
was a great guy, had a
little charisma, was a great
storyteller, knew how not to
blow up the spot of his fellow
athletes, showed the real life
of being on a bus before the
game, with fans, his own life,
his crazy brother, his awesome
mom I think that that
is the person right now.
The most charismatic storyteller
that could be doing it with a
phone that happens not be the
best player on the team has the
most storytelling capabilities
that hasn't been deployed yet.
- [Niklas] Awesome.
- Gilbert Arenas did this.
Gilbert Arenas was a very nice
up-and-coming NBA player who
then had some big-time seasons
who was the first guy to blog
and use MySpace way back when
and became much more famous than
he actually was and got better
endorsement deals because of it.
So that's who I would say.
It's really anybody who is a
B or C list celebrity or athlete
that needs to act like me
or Casey or Nash Greer
or Musical.ly stars.
They need to the internet thing
while they're on the
mainstream plateau.
- [Niklas] Mhmmm.
Awesome.
Then I get a chance
to ask a question.
- You get to ask a question?
- Yes.
- This is a very big
moment, Professor.
Can I call you "Professor"?
- Yes, actually--
- Professor.
Put up a big, Staphon, little
editing for you professor.
- If the Attorney General
was forbidding you to--
- This is actually the question?
- yes,--
- Oh shit.
- and forced you to go
teaching for a semester--
- I would be A pumped.
As long as everybody else
couldn't run businesses either.
If I was just picked on I'd be
pissed that sounds like
more like communism.
A, if everybody
was, I'd be happy.
It's the same I feel about
the last two weeks of August.
Do you know I'm
comfortably taking
off for the last two weeks
of August?
Because most people take the
last two weeks of August and
I know there's not going to be
as much productivity and so
I'm not falling too far behind.
If I had to teach a
semester, what's the question?
- How would you structure and
teach social media marketing?
- I would probably if I was
allowed to on a university level
I probably would be and
obviously take out the
economics, could we afford to,
I would try and get them out of
the room, out of the classroom
as much as possible whether
physically or mentally and what
I mean by that is mentally we
would be in our
apps doing, creating.
I would get kids out of, if I was
in Chapman in California I would
go to local businesses I would
take the 29 kids in class
we'd go to Lou's pizza shop.
Be like "Lou, we're here.
And were here to work.
"What do you need?"
I very much believe, I'm so
proud of you I was so thankful
that you reached out to me and
you're taking us up on this week
because you're
going to go be better.
You're gonna go back to school
and what you're gonna learn this
week you're going to be better.
- Yeah.
- Because it's real.
This is real.
- Mhmmm.
- The classroom is less real.
It's less of the
market, it just is.
My answer to your question is
I would force them
to do real shit.
- Yeah.
- I would just try to get them
do as much real stuff
as much as possible.
You can watch GaryVee videos,
you can read books,
you can pontificate,
you can debate but
nothing beats getting thrown.
I can tell kids about swimming.
Okay, so what you
want to do is, right?
I can tell you.
We can debate what
the best stroke is.
But how are you going
to be a good swimmer?
You're going to throw
that kid in the pool.
I would put the kids in as many
real life situations as possible
and I would do in a
couple different ways.
One, I would try to use my
connections if I was allowed to
based on this fantasy world
you've created and get them to
go to Under Armour or a Toyota
see how they think about it.
But then I'd also do a
competition the last
three weeks of the semester
I would say okay we're
all going to go to the
farmer's market.
You all have three weeks to
figure out what you're going to
sell in a farmers market and
then all you can use is digital
for the whole three weeks
leading up to it and then
whoever sells the
most fruit wins.
Try to get them into that kind
of mentality because
I think that matters.
I'm very scared, Professor,
of eighth place trophies.
I'm very scared of rewarding
people for success
that isn't real.
We would have the fruit and
vegetable farmers market
competition and then the
next day in class I would say
unbelievable job Sally and
I would say Elliott you suck.
You are a loser, you sold eight
dollars in radishes and
let's break down why you sucked.
Your Instagram was boring,
I don't know what the hell
you were thinking.
Your radishes look like shit
so let's start with the biggest
thesis which is no
marketing fixes crap product.
So these are the things
that we would go through.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I will use this for my class.
Thanks.
- Thanks for being on.
Question of the day.
You get to ask it, my friend.
You get to ask the Vayner Nation
any question that you
want, Professor.
Answer the Professor's question.
- In terms of a CEO what would
you advice would you give to
them to humanize their brands?
And then what platforms
and what media formats?
- Detail.
- Yeah, detail, examples,
state of the art, 2016 August.
- Love it.
Thanks you, my friend.
- Awesome.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.